So here we have it. Transcription. A promoter
region, a sequence of DNA, tells proteins exactly where
transcription should start in a particular region. And we
call this region the transcription start site. And at
this point, individual RNA nucleotides are going to be
brought in and matched with the DNA. One by
one. And this will continue, until we reach the
end of the gene. So on a molecular level,
you really get a feel for the chemistry that's going
on here. And so for us to really see what's going
on at this point, we need to zoom out a little
bit more. So if we take a look at the DNA
gene as a whole, from start to stop. This is
where transcription started, and this is where transcription ends. This was
the full length of the DNA gene that we wanted to
transcribe and eventually turn into protein. The RNA copy is actually
called an mRNA copy. mRNA means Messenger RNA. It
turns out that RNA serves many purposes in a
cell. And so there are lots of prefixes for
RNA that distinguishes what it can do. And the most
important one for us is this messenger status. Because
the messenger means that it was a copy made
from a DNA gene, and that's eventually going to
be turned into protein. We call this our mRNA or
our messenger RNA copy. Now you might notice
a couple of differences, from our DNA gene. And
our mRNA copy. I've drawn these images to be
representative of some distinguishing characteristics of the process. So
I want you to tell me, how does this mRNA copy differ compared to the DNA gene
that it came from? I'm not going to give you
any answers to choose from, just a text box.
I'd like for you to organize your thoughts and try to answer
this question. Don't worry about getting this right or wrong. Just look at
the difference between the gene and the mRNA and whatever difference you
notice, I want you to write it down in the text box here.